Naughty Dog's long-awaited sequel The
Last of Us part two is finally out in
the wild here are seven spoiler free
tips to give you an edge as you fight
your way through this cruel and violent
world number one looting and crafting
looting is a big part of the last of us
as gameplay loop in between each
encounter you should be scanning the
environment look for drawers cupboards
and other compartments as you clear
abandoned buildings and rusted out cars
as you Luke you'll find supplies which
you can use to craft things like arrows
explosives and explosive arrows the
amount of supplies you can find will
directly coincide with the difficulty
you choose if you pick easy you'll find
plenty of crafting parts and if you
choose survivor you probably won't find
many if you picked an easier difficulty
you'll probably run out of space often
so make sure you craft things as
frequently as possible if you're playing
survivor crafts wisely if you ever feel
as though you're under prepared or over
prepared for fire fights we recommend
adjusting the difficulty because you can
do so at any time number two difficulty
and accessibility speaking of difficulty
The Last of Us part two has a ton of
difficulty and accessibility options for
you to tweak and manipulate to your
heart's content you can adjust the enemy
AI the amount of resources you can find
the damage the player takes and how
capable your allies are you can even go
into the accessibility options and
further tweak the gameplay to suit your
play style number three collectibles
Naughty Dog love's collectibles and the
Last of Us part two is no different
collectibles come in many forms
including artifacts trading cards and
journal entries artifacts mostly consist
of notes that add flavor to the area you
are exploring trading cards are cards
that Ellie is into and journal entries
are things in the environment that Ellie
will sketch if you interact with it most
collectibles can only be found in
non-combat areas however there are a few
exceptions the most notable one is
hidden under a bed in the Hillcrest
section so keep your eyes peeled if
you're a completionist we recommend
turning on high contrast mode and
enhance listen mode in the accessibility
menu high contrast mode will highlight
things in your environment you can
interact with by swiping the touchpad
and enhance listening mode will ping
nearby items number for safes as you
explore the world you'll also come
across locked combination safes these
safes contain training manuals which
unlock new skills new weapons and of
course extra
on supplies if you find a safe it's in
your best interest to crack it to do
that you'll need to find the combination
somewhere in the environment many can be
found on letters left behind however
there are a few trickier ones that
require you to survey the environment
carefully the combination will almost
always be close to the safe itself
number five bricks and bottles break
bones now that we have that out of the
way let's talk about combat part twos
combat is fast tense and difficult if
you aren't prepared if you find yourself
low on ammo or supplies look for bricks
or bottles in the environment not only
can you use them to distract enemies but
a well-thrown bottle or brick can also
stun an enemy serving them up for an
easy kill
this can be clutched on harder
difficulties when supplies and ammo are
scarce number six dogs new to the last
of us are dogs as much as it pains me to
kill these not-so-good boys it is in
your best interest to dispatch them
quickly if a dog catches your scent it
will follow it until it finds you or
loses the trail you can see your scent
by holding our one to activate listen
mode a good way to take care of a dog on
your trail is by placing a tripmine
eventually the dog will get close enough
to set it off and I wouldn't recommend
looking that direction when it does if
you'd rather do with them non lethally a
well-thrown brick or bottle can also
throw them off your scent number seven
run
[Music]
just like in The Last of Us one you can
run from most encounters if you're
spotted while you're trying to stealth
through an area you can run out of the
enemy's line-of-sight and reposition
yourself or you can simply try to run to
the next area if you play on the
survivor difficulty setting running is a
totally viable option that will help you
conserve your precious ammo those are
seven tips that should help you stay
alive in the last of us part two if you
have any other things you'd like to add
leave them in the comments below and
we'll see you next time
you